[Music]
just from the title alone there are a
few things you can expect from a Tales
game a lengthy story melodramatic
writing dated visuals and of course a
real-time battle system for the most
part tales of verse area sticks to the
same formula the story is long and
punctuated with both predictable and
unexpected plot twists the writing can
swing from tender moments to
cringe-worthy ones and the real-time
combat is engaging but becomes stale
near the end where tales of Bruce area
differentiates itself from recent
entries is its mature story in
characters
[ __ ] demons velvet crow the
protagonist is introduced as a wholesome
young woman taking care of her younger
brother in a world overrun by demons
after her brother is sacrificed in order
to quell the evil in the world
velvet is transformed into a demon and
locked away in prison the opening hours
are slow but after they come to a close
tails of Bruce area quickly spirals into
a story of revenge when we revisit
velvet three years later she is no
longer the innocent wholesome girl from
the prologue she is angry what's
striking about velvet as opposed to past
tales protagonist is that she is driven
by rage and vengeance knock them back
that's an order
not
back or I'll eat you
now the darker tone makes up for tales
of verse areas slow first few hours
while the series has never shied away
from heavy themes it's refreshing to
play as a character in a Tales game
who's willing to do whatever it takes in
order to get what she wants she's not
afraid to kill steal and threaten when
it's necessary her apathy can get
exhausting at times even frustrating but
her motives are believable we'll take
this back to town and tell him you're
dead that should be enough to satisfy
the Exorcist and get them to call off
the search the same can be said about
the supporting cast of party members
however the standout character is
Eleanor unlike the rest of the team
Eleanor is virtuous she tries to help
people and do what she thinks is right
throughout most of the game she's at
odds with the company she keeps and
finds herself stuck between two very
different worlds
this foil creates an uneasy tension and
at times adds a much-needed reprieve
from Velvets cruelty no this is personal
once I regain my Exorcist powers
I vow to challenge you demon velvet the
other half of the experience comes in
the form of combat as expected the
trademark tails real-time battle system
returns but not without some changes
tales of Bruce area removes the
technical points bar and replaces it
with the soul gauge which is similar in
that it dictates how long you can chain
together combat and spell arts however
unlike in previous Tales games you can
steal Souls from your opponents by
knocking them out or stunning them the
soul gauge doesn't change the flow of
battle too much but it does add a bit
more fluidity to it the game offers a
wide variety of arts across all six
party members and as long as you have
enough souls you can chain any of them
together to create unique combos tales
games have always allowed for this kind
of experimentation but linking arts
hasn't felt this fluid or captivating
before once you get comfortable with the
combat you can keep the momentum of
battle going for minutes at a time
well that takes care of that but no
amount of experimentation can salvage
the repetitive nature of tales of Bruce
area the delight in unlocking new arts
fades about halfway through the game and
by then the battles become tedious near
the end I found myself focusing more on
avoiding enemies rather than trying
different characters or testing out new
arts this repetition extends to the
world and dungeon design like tales of
zestiria and tales of Xillia verse area
doesn't have an overworld instead you
travel from town to town by trekking
through large sectioned off areas which
could easily be confused with locations
from previous Tales games there isn't
much to do or see in these areas either
apart from fighting enemies and hunting
for treasure chests the dungeon design
is even worse dungeons consists of long
corridors that occasionally branch off
simple puzzles and dozens of similar
enemies apart from a palette swap these
multi-level dungeons look identical from
floor to floor textures and objects are
reused from corridor to corridor making
it a pain to navigate the puzzles don't
require much thought either in most
cases you flip a switch or light a torch
and the door opens it doesn't help that
tales of per serie looks dated at times
it's indistinguishable from 2013's tales
of Xillia the art direction can go a
long way at times to mitigate the poor
graphics especially in some later
dungeons but don't expect to be blown
away by it
demon blight has spread through the
village
do not fear with my power as an extra
system
I Artorius co-brand will end your pain
tales of Bruce areas weak presentation
until world design may be off-putting
but that only accounts for part of an
otherwise enjoyable tale the refined
combat in the darker tone paired with
the sinister characters makes for a more
engaging experience overall tales of
Bruce area may not reinvent the series
but it does take steps in an intriguing
new direction
[Music]